voyons voyons dans la croyance dans
l'affectation à la même chose moi je ne
confonds pas les musulmans avec les
islamistes jamais je les confondrait et
c'est ce qui fait la différence entre
l'extrême droite et la droite mais
madame occasion
de sortir un quart d'heure si vous
y
aller donc gg je tire pas les y couper
bah je conclus là-dessus non écoutez moi
je vais vous dire je suis très à l'aise
là dessus en effet l'islamisme est une
lecture fondamentalisme de l'islam vous
le savez je pense que personne n'imagine
que les djihadistes sont des bouddhistes
radicaliser ce sont malgré tout des
musulmans radicaliser donc il est
évident qu'il y a aujourd'hui un lien
dire que ça se confond totalement de
fait il ya évidemment une différence
puisqu'il ya une lecture fondamentaliste
dire que ça n'a rien à voir ça me semble
aussi un petit peu un petit peu délicat
et compliqué après c'est vrai que je
pense qu'il ya une à une il ya une vraie
différence aujourd'hui entre nous alors
vous allez dire c'est la différence
entre la droite et d'extrême droite que
c'est votre argument ce soir mais au
delà de la question de l'iran - la
différence entre moi eric zemmour c'est
la différence sur la question de
l'islamisme sur la lutte contre
l'islamisme dont je pense qu'une façon
que ça fait l'unanimité dans le
globalement dans la vie politique
française mais ce qui est vrai c'est que
ce que je crois et sur la question de
l'immigration notamment et c'est vrai
que je n'entends pas cette dimension
civilisationnelle dans votre discours
c'est que demain si l'islam est
majoritaire en france c'est nous avons
une majorité de compatriotes ou deux
personnes qui sont de nationalité de
cours d'hier de confession musulmane sur
le territoire français à l'absolu sera à
l'honneur si vous voulez de confession
musulmane sur le sur le territoire
français permettez moi de dire que le
visage de la france va complètement
changer ça mais c'est ça qu'il faut des
vraies bonnes réponses avec des quotas
ça vous pose un problème que demain
l'islam potentiellement sont
majoritaires en france où est ce que
pour vous c'est pas un sujet toute façon
les peuples sont interchangeables c'est
une question de religion c'est du privé
mais madame le pen est ce que c'est un
débat d' extrêmement inquiet madame le
pen vraiment vous avez l'art de ne pas
répondre à ne pas répondre à la vraie
question n'est pas ne pas répondre avec
six mois je vais répondre ou alors alors
elles ont dévoilé aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce que je souhaite c'est que
on est une vraie politique de régulation
des flux migratoires et qu'on ait une
vraie c'est parce qu'au développement de
l'afrique si parce que ça te faire mais
ça permet aujourd'hui c'est pas avec des
choux ah non j'ai toujours ma question
c'est très important la question c'est
que les impôts et sans fondement si
l'islam est majoritaire en france vous
considérez que c'est un sujet où ça
n'est pas un sujet que ça changera
strictement rien que finalement c'est
pas un enjeu historique complotistes de
la peur et de la haine qui permet qui
vous permet d'exister et qui vous permet
aujourd'hui
de essayer de fédérer la question
ne
s'est pas séparé les théories
complotistes qui n'aidait se passe à dix
sont là elles sont la fasnet mieux pour
faire peur et que pour susciter pour ça
les complotistes en france 66 % des
français considèrent que le grand
emplacement est une réalité il ya
aujourd'hui une vraie réalité il ya une
vraie réalité de l'immigration
aujourd'hui incontrôlées donc c'est pour
ça je lutte contre et c'est pour ça que
patrick stefanini que vous citez sont
qu'il est aujourd'hui directeur de ma
campagne et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
on est en train de même cible à 6 on est
en train de même air china effectué une
vraie politique pour lutter contre merci
vos théories ou nova se réaliseront